hello there video game developers have
taken each other's ideas countless times
throughout the history of gaming because
a good idea is a good idea epic games
and fortnite aren't above this either
and over the course of fortnite's
meteoric growth to where it is now
they've shall we say borrowed a few
concepts from their competitors i'm adam
maru here's my creator code if you're
interested and now sit your butt down
for 10 minutes while we uncover 16 times
fortnite stole from other games oh and
please don't see this as an attack on
epic it isn't i just want to see who
deserves the credit for the things we
love in fortnite
[Music]
okay let's start with the latest and
greatest example of this fortnight's
imposter game mode the moment we all saw
this we knew this was fortnite's among
us and it's impossible not to see the
similarities both modes have a team of
innocent parties completing tasks to win
the game and then there's two imposters
running around attempting to sabotage
and eliminate those innocent players the
tasks vary and the sabotages are
different but at its core it's the exact
same game epic simply took it i
personally prefer fortnite version 2
among us but credit where credit is due
among us did this first this story gets
a little more cutting when we found out
that the among us team had tried in vain
to speak to epic about a crossover
between the two games epic instead
decided to simply do it for themselves
leaving the originators feeling stabbed
in the back i still hold hope that a
crossover will be possible but a bridge
has definitely been burned between the
two companies
fortnite had everything going for it in
chapter one season four and five grew
the player base exponentially and
everything was rosy but suddenly on
february 4th 2019 a new battle royale
game appeared apex legends it took the
battle royale genre and added its own
spin and oh my gosh it scared the hell
out of epic games so much so that they
added multiple ideas from apex to keep
the lead in the br race one of the
biggest draws to apex was the ability to
pick up your teammate once they fell in
battle their hollow card banner could be
grabbed and rushed to the nearest
respawn beacon which would bring them
back from the clutches of death not only
is this a fun mechanic it also makes
players who may have been eliminated
earlier in the game still engage with it
and be part of the team epic saw this
and one day later yes just one day they
said this a new feature landing in
fortnite next week the reboot fan lose a
squad mate early in the match bring him
back and finish strong less than 24
hours that took i for one i'm glad they
did copy this mechanic because i die
die so much apex was a real contender in
2019 and the reboot vans were only the
start of things which fortnight borrowed
the thing we all take for granted when
playing today is the ping system marking
points of interest and weapons and
enemies and consumables this mechanic is
vital these days and it's tough to think
back to a time when it wasn't here that
so happens to be back when apex arrived
and their innovative one-button ping
system made communicating even without a
mic a complete breeze respawn received
heavy praise for this system and look
only a fortnight later see what i did
there it was in fortnite apex released
with a trio's game mode and it just so
happened that a few days before apex
became available epic was testing a trio
mode themselves this could be
coincidence or it could mean that they
had seen the closed testing for apex and
realized trios is a big deal and people
want to play it however you see this the
sweatiest mode in fortnite br is most
likely influenced by apex legends
[Music]
before battle royale took over the
gaming space there was another king of
games overwatch a hero shooter which
puts characters at the forefront with
personalities and defining
characteristics fortnight took
inspiration from these established
characters and straight up took them
made a couple of changes and sold them
to the community here's only a few of
them because this would take all day
overwatch's mercy is an angel complete
with halo and winks and a segmented
white dress and this is fortnite's ark
an angel complete with halo and wings
and a segmented white dress
that must be a coincidence right this is
overwatch's widow maker a
spider-inspired femme fatale and this is
fortnite's arachne a spider-inspired
femme fatale there's a theme here one of
my own kin tracer don't worry loves
cavalry's ear
looks a great deal like rocks they even
strike the same pose too and what about
a mega and genji i think you get the
idea what's your take on this have
fortnite been copying overwatch's
homework or is everything a coincidence
and good ideas are good ideas
fortnite has seen many copycats over the
years trying to build a reputation by
mimicking its success one of these games
was realm royale which introduced a
mechanic to select where on the island
you wanted to dive to it was great and
helped the whole squad know exactly
where they were going before they even
left the fake battle bus this was so
helpful in squad games that epic grabbed
this and applied it to fortnite and
eventually that became part of the ping
system we talked about earlier but this
wasn't the only time a copycat of
fortnite had the attention of epic games
did you ever play the creative
destruction game it's 100
a fortnight rip-off right down to the
cartoonish aesthetic but even this had
new ideas to add to the br formula one
of these was a weapon called the
destructor a two-handed weapon which
literally ripped apart the buildings in
front of you epic decided to take
inspiration from the game that took
inspiration from them and gave us the
recycler a weapon that could both rip
buildings to pieces and also fire them
at enemies the recycler's effective and
explosive attack will deal damage to
enemies and help you tear down their
builds other weapons and items have a
history before fortnite any team
fortress 2 fans in the house in team
fortress 2 the medic class can be chosen
and they use a bazooka-style weapon to
heal their teammates
does it look familiar that bazooka was
added to fortnite and shot out a steady
stream of bandages and when this was
iterated upon and the chug cannon was
released it looked even closer to the
original design found in team fortress
2.
epic have actually stolen from epic in
the past too let me explain all the
previous games they've worked on have
impacted fortnite in many ways for
example the original knocked animation
was taken from gears of war when they
made the original game before microsoft
moved that franchise to another team the
down but not out mechanic became so
loved by gamers that it's in most things
you play these days a second chance to
be revived and brought back into the
match if you saw my last video about
secrets in the new imposter game mode
you'll have seen me talk about the
infinity blade put simply infinity blade
assets were directly taken from that now
dead game and brought to life in
fortnite the rune language we all love
kevin the cube for isn't a new concept
at all it's been here all along in
infinity blade they just grabbed it and
put it in fortnite i don't think we can
call this theft this is more a reuse of
assets but it shows once again that
other games heavily inspire fortnite
right down to the mysteries of kevin the
cube
one last apex piece of thievery epic was
so worried by apex legends that they
decided to give away the season 8
fortnight battle pass for free to
everyone foregoing millions upon
millions of dollars to get people back
on board playing their game and it just
so happens that the tier 100 skin for
that season was this lady looks
and i hate to say this but she looks
heavily inspired by lifeline from apex
and once you see it it's hard to unsee
it from the way her clothes sit her skin
complexity and of course the signature
lifeline hair another thing apex
pioneered our emotes while skydiving and
two years later we are starting to see
them used in fortnite there's only one
right now do you know what it is it's
superman he's the only skin with a
totally unique diving animation with his
legendary pose hey i'm not saying
fortnite are taken from apex again but
if in a year's time we are all back
flipping out the battle bus i think we
know who to credit
there's a ton more we could talk about
so let's quickly give a few an honorable
mention fortnite introduced gold and
bounties after seeing the success of
cash and bounties in call of duty war
zone at the time that was their closest
competitor but it isn't always battle
royale they take from grabbing a chicken
in fortnite is actually taken from a
certain nintendo game which has had that
for years the legend of zelda traveling
far and wide quickly and safely has been
almost perfectly recreated in fortnite i
think we can safely say the developers
of fortnite play a lot of video games so
there we have it 16 times epic stole
ideas to improve fortnite wherever you
sit on this subject i think it's
important to applaud the games that
inspired the current fortnite world and
in particular games like apex legends
that push epic into evolving their game
for future years now though i throw this
to you can you tell me any games that
have stolen from fortnite and let's make
a video of the other side of this
argument what do you say i'm adam you're
awesome here's a bunch of legends who
are kind enough to use code adamara in
the store thank you so much you keep me
going every week much appreciated i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you